[Music]
we go only cut something
go get her again
[Music]
running away
[Music]
what are you not so what Roberto
Clemente out of respect J Bashar up in
Pittsburgh gave me this shirt one of the
greatest [ __ ] humans baseball players
humanitarian you know you know how we do
it
this keeps token here so our guest comes
up jessimae [ __ ] Peluso spear
tonight from girlcode
seasons 1 & 2 she's one of [ __ ]
that's the cool cool bars you know we do
it though it's just a Monday on the map
you joined us for this [ __ ] uncle
Joey and we say at TV on periscope you
know this is it people
you're with family you're smoking a ball
listen to pay for but what do you expect
Oh baby you know I love you mother
[ __ ] if not I wouldn't be here
sitting again I would I don't like
getting high with [ __ ] people I don't
know but look I'm with you I can be
[ __ ] smoking dope with the DA right
now I can be smoking my merch so we can
change thank you what's up you bad
[ __ ] man I'm in the house took a
shower for you mother that's right and
everything you want some water you want
a smoke
oh you want some mushrooms
the murky waters the other world you how
we do it
this is really cute yes as some kid made
it for us in Austin yeah that's my girl
I'll do deals worth it
yeah yeah that's always this the most
worth they say she knows I am Sarita
maybe a piece of nicotine gum and you
put on some weight you put on some
reading glasses quiet you know we've got
time to fool around
look at this look at this opium den of
love that we love to get smoked
everywhere people passing out yeah but
Ryan jiu-jitsu jiu-jitsu straight up so
January I've been doing it for three
years but never was consistent I always
had [ __ ] and now I joined this [ __ ]
school when I'm inconsistent you guys
different you know what everything feels
better I'm doing that CBD long muscle
seven drops in my mouth yeah I'm gonna
have to get on the show I'm gonna try
from one I see what's you know see
what's going on
that's right [ __ ] get yourself
together over there jessimae Peluso from
the cliffside punk Palouse those in the
[Music]
mushroom pink floyd--
do what you do do what you do they're
all looking beautiful issues
jessimae Peluso in the house taking the
head down that's what my reefa does he
might cease to start a debt she'll be
running since Studio City balls ass make
it what what inception right there
periscope meets periscope who the [ __ ]
does this [ __ ]
who does this construct as you you never
[Music]
that's perenial appearing in a studio
city you can smoke your Wii with your
class something's gonna get sued a lot
of times this is hard and I'm gonna pull
it off and it's [ __ ] nightmare so I
told him earlier Sunday somebody's what
what you tapped in yeah and right here
with the flavors jessimae Peluso uncle
Joey will be coming into it in about
[ __ ] 10 minutes on YouTube hardcore
jitter juice we [ __ ] around
it's a Tony Bennett type of Monday
leaves on muscle I hate mushrooms
edibles we don't stop here at the church
understand me we're going for [ __ ]
broke [ __ ] you [ __ ] and think
that yeah over here watching these
comedians and these [ __ ] people and
got the balls and nothing and we're over
here fight for our [ __ ] lives
[ __ ] get it together YouTube the
church 10 minutes
[Music]